hey everyone welcome to the water layer
podcast I'm your host James Marshall and
as soon as we drop the c-elysée ray RC
episode I've been getting bombarded with
messages about playing this prank we
talked about it in pretty long
discussion in that last episode so it's
only fair that I play it for you guys
now if you are easily offended please
don't listen to it please just turn off
your device and just wait for the next
episode but if you enjoy a laugh and
enjoy a good prank well then this is for
you so here it goes
enjoy hey so atheist its don t here so
they say yeah really good thank you
thank you so much for leaving me call me
that's over topic I'm really nervous
good I just love the way you play yeah I
enter the competition and and I can't
read you - cool oh now I just have a
couple of questions they'd like to ask
game sure won't deal I've always wanted
to play for the Hurricanes and then and
I got a couple friends of mine years of
my favorite times composer team as well
so that was probably the main there's
one of the reasons you know if it's
either I've got a couple teammates are
you a couple minutes on the team that I
know quite well you know mainly why come
here sir yeah all in Orleans yeah
one of the reasons well what about a
current man that's in the team at the
moment that you're playing with
oh me too
I have you and baby here and do you
think we'd be able to meet them and if
we got me what would you like to do not
squeezing this was my rock my Tiki
brother right but he wanted to know if
you've got a big penis what's the answer
oh I like to have a media I just want a
night a
if you didn't realize I am gay so I do I
[Laughter]
love you work she loved jaunty